[Music]
all right let's go to sue in
philadelphia what is up sue
hi
hi doctor john how are you i'm so good
how are you
i'm okay
um my husband has bipolar
and he tends to be manic for about a
year and then he tends to be depressed
for about a year
and we have kids
and life is really hard with the kids
when he's depressed because he doesn't
want anything to do with us and he says
dumb stuff to the kids
and when he's manic he does dumb stuff
um
we did fpu and we're on track to be out
of baby step two
next summer and he recently went and
bought a rental house
with no money because we're on baby
stuff too oh jeez so
he doesn't want any help he thinks he's
good i need help like this is taking a
toll on me physically yes i need help
for me and my kids
oh man
number one i'm sorry
number two
i have to go talk to some friends a
couple friends of mine who are experts
on this i've not heard of
annual cycling before
that seems like a long ramp up and a
long
ramp down
it really is and that i did
give him an ultimatum to go to a
counselor once quite a few years ago and
the counselor kind of said the same
thing but that
that is what we're seeing it's a long
time who diagnosed him
um
it was a local
psychologist maybe okay i don't even
know how long
i went with him
uh that was probably nine years ago okay
it's time to go get that stuff checked
up uh well i'm gonna speak to you as
though he is somebody who's invested in
being well and then i'm because there's
you know people listening who are into
that
and into
into that into into loving their
families and taking care of themselves
and then i'm gonna
dig into the reality that you're facing
is that cool
that's cool um
somebody with a bipolar diagnosis i want
them getting reassessed every couple of
years um if not sooner than that
um you should be
on meds you should have a really active
wellness plan
and you should have people in your life
that are walking alongside you
and
nine years ago no medications no
counseling no nothing is a recipe for
disaster if it's true bipolar
i
just like the counselor you met with
i've not heard off top of my head i
can't think of anyone who's i've ever
heard of who's got annual cycles like
that and for those listening who don't
know annual cycle b
normally these are two or three month
waves sometimes they're shorter than
that
i haven't heard of a wave going for 12
months low and then 12 months up
that i wonder if something else is at
play does he does he have a drug
problem too
no
so he's totally sober
and so let's deal with reality here
he won't take medication is that right
right he was depressed last year and um
he did eventually go to a counselor but
he switched counselors and he wouldn't
let me go with because he likes the
feeling of being manic so he just told
them that he was depressed and he told
them nothing about his manic speeches
so they just diagnosed him with
depression tell me about your ultimatum
um i had told him that if he didn't go
see a counselor i was going to leave him
yeah
when you say he says dumb things to the
kids what does he say
um so last year multiple times a day he
would
tell the kids that he needed them to put
his head on straight
and it really like my one daughter in
particular really took a toll on her
and no matter how much i told him that
the kids couldn't handle it he didn't
stop yeah
what what prompted this call did
something happen recently
um well he bought this rental building
but i'm
i feel like i'm starting to struggle
with anxiety well yeah of course because
you're
absolutely
i mean y'all we're in the middle of an
economic mess right now and this is not
the time to be buying
house homes at their highly inflated
prices with no money down like
it's just yeah it's not a great moment
to be doing that your body is letting
you know we're not safe and you know
this
um the term we use around here with my
buddy dave
is financial infidelity
that level of deceit and
um
lack of safety and like core value
violation
is a big deal
if you're hiding if you're buying things
and hiding it you're buying things that
you didn't agree on if you say hey we're
in on this plan and somebody did
something different
that's infidelity it's dishonesty it
hurts at a really deep level um what was
your post conversation when you found
out how'd that go
um
i well
when it comes to fight or flight i'm
definitely flight so i just kind of
clammed up i knew it was too late there
was nothing that
i could do to stop it
so
that's kind of the point where
i don't know i'm
not really talking like he's trying to
show me how this is a good thing all the
time and
i just kind of battle up
yeah
so what's your or what
i don't know
i'm christian and i do believe
that divorce probably isn't an option
okay
i took our vows seriously but i don't
know
i don't know what options i do have
i mean you can stay or you can leave
right
so let's go with the option that you're
gonna stay
at some point you make peace with this
is who he is
we have ups and we have downs
and i'm going to put some very serious
roadblocks between me and him because
i've got to keep my family safe
okay
and
that might look like
making sure like letting him know i'm
never gonna hide stuff i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna contribute to
his misbehavior
by me lessening my character right but
it may be i need you to know i'm
carrying forward with this i'm not going
to be a part of it i don't want to be on
the i mean i don't know now you're
getting to like i'm i'm hesit as i'm
speaking out loud i don't like the words
that are coming out of my mouth
let me put it this way sue this is
really bad
right
um
this
is he in a manic season right now
he is
so tell me tell me what that's like
um
he gets up at like three o'clock in the
morning
and he's going all day at work
and then he comes home and eats and
falls asleep on the couch and
that's pretty much our days and he does
whatever he wants
you don't have a marriage you know that
right
i do know that
have you met with somebody
i have not
that's your step next step
okay okay
because you've got some
uh
religious values which are really
important you've got some
uh
realities
can i
you're not telling me everything
about how he acts is that fair
uh
yeah maybe yeah maybe
um there are some things going on that
aren't okay and you know that and i know
that
and you're trying to keep things held
together how old are your little ones
uh they range in age from 10 to 17. okay
that's a lot of hurt on those kids
yeah
so what i want you to do is this um here
ultimately for everybody listening
you've got to get to an or what moment
either i accept the way my life is and
i'm going to be okay with it i'm going
to make peace with it i'm going to find
joy in the pockets with which i've been
dealt
or
i have an or what moment where
you will
go to counseling with me and i will have
full access to the therapy records
because your bipolar impacts all of us
you will get on some sort of medication
regimen you will get new psychometric
testing to find out where you even are
because this doesn't sound right to me
and again i'm just a podcast guy i'm not
a full-time psychologist so there you go
right here um
it doesn't it's not passing my initial
smell test i could be way off but it's
just not um
and he has to decide i want to love my
family
i want to love my wife i want to be
connected to them
and so in my seasons of bipolar which by
the way bipolar is super real when it's
real
i'm going to not have my atm card i am
going to not have access to our bank
accounts i'm going to not have access to
the internet
or to
my vehicle or to cell phones or because
i make terrible decisions
and when i'm in slow seasons
i am going to put my lights in my
bedroom on a timer so i get up i am
going to have a
trainer that's going to show up at my
house and call me i will go see a
counselor i will take my medication so
there's things you put up put in in
in a line before these things happen
and they don't fully solve the things if
you will but they create a life that is
sustainable for the person involved and
for the family and my hypothesis is over
time
the severities begin to lessen
a lot of data on that but that's my
guess you begin to practice living in a
new way
but you got to decide i want to do that
and okay you can't make him do that
that's his call
all you can do is say i'm gonna take
care of me i'm gonna love me i'm gonna
love these kids i'm gonna make sure they
know they are loved make sure they know
dad is sick he's not well and dad's
choosing to not get well and it's not a
mat it's not a reflection of them
it's a reflection of him
and
i've got to come up with i've got to
make peace with my life
or i've got to come up with an or what
moment and then decide what's next for
all of us
okay is that fair
yeah at the end of the day you can
control three things
your thoughts your actions your desire
to get well and get connected that's it
and it feels powerless especially when
you're married to somebody who has no
interest in being well or changing their
life to help
themselves and the rest of the family
man i wish we could leave this on some
super hopeful high note
um
i've just seen this too much until
somebody gets invested in their wellness
there's not a lot people can do other
than take care of themselves and also
this so you haven't taken care of sue in
a long time either
and it's
time you look in the mirror and say you
know what sue i'm worth it you're worth
it let's make this happen
let's take care of ourselves